golpeados con bastones y sometidos al
frío y al hambre son las condiciones de
cautiverio en las que permanecieron
estos menores nigerianos durante seis
días secuestrados al noroeste del país
llegaron a casa en la ciudad de katsina
este viernes muchos de ellos descalzos y
envueltos en mantas al principio no se
escondieron a todos en el mismo lugar
pero cuando vieron un avión de combate
cambiaron la ubicación y nos escondieron
en un lugar diferente nos dieron comida
pero era muy poca las autoridades
dijeron que el rescate ocurrió el jueves
pero muchos detalles siguen sin
esclarecerse incluyendo si se pagó la
liberación de los niños
hoy gloria a dios estamos aquí con ellos
para entregar los estudiantes al estado
antes de su posterior entrega a sus
padres las autoridades informaron
inicialmente de más de 300 estudiantes
desaparecidos pero en un vídeo bucarám
afirmó a través de la voz de un joven de
unos 14 años que tenían 520 niños en sus
manos y que algunos sabían
y asesinados
para que aprovecho esta oportunidad para
elogiar y agradecer los esfuerzos
realizados por todo el aparato de
seguridad del estado por lo que hicieron
el profesionalismo que se demostró
durante los esfuerzos que culminaron con
la liberación de estos 300 44
estudiantes
que según los oficiales este secuestro
en masa fue coordinado por una banda que
responde directamente a las órdenes de
evacuar am la participación de este
grupo yihadista marcaría una expansión
geográfica de sus actividades desde su
base en el noreste del país
el ataque fue además una bofetada en la
cara del presidente muhammadu buhari
quien ha dicho repetidamente que bucarám
está técnicamente derrotado